you
[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up Roth today we can discuss a
few issues that have cropped up in our
late recent discussions and we will get
right into it
hello Walter how are you doing I'm well
and you I'm fine
can I ask for you to please open a king
with app word of Prayer for us there's
been a complaint that I am always the
one that is praying so I think you can
show them today that you are also a
prayer warrior absolutely let's pray
however Li father thank you very much
for giving us the privilege to come into
your throne room and we can stand in
service of you we ask that you bless
this discussion and that you open our
minds were the Holy Spirit's in working
and that you will bless the people that
watch this in Jesus name Amen so what
are the issues we are going to discuss
today well there are quite a few issues
that the people in the discussion in our
previous videos bring up and they would
like to know what our position on these
issues is that's a good point
some of these issues are for instance
the 5g the chip mark of the beast' that
we've already discussed in the previous
lectures and I would just like to tell
the viewers you know this is a
discussion this is not an in-depth study
of these issues so when we do this
discussion we will put links to lectures
that do in-depth discussions of these
issues so we encourage you please go and
have a look at the links and most of
your questions in the discussions will
be answered through those lectures so if
it's okay with you let's discuss some of
it and what is your thoughts on this
broad spectrum of all those questions
yeah my my position is actually quite
simple what do we believe why do we
believe it what is our duty in terms of
times we are living in and I think
there's a lot of confusion out there
because as you raise the point there
there are so many issues that people are
bringing in at the moment which clamor
for the attention of the mind that the
the broad objective of preaching the
gospel is getting lost in the background
noise and I find it fascinating that we
should have all of these points being
raised you mentioned the feasts news the
question of the deity of Christ the
Godhead and all of these theological
issues which now seem to be concentrated
in this time in which we are living the
issue of perfection how perfect must we
be in order to stand before God when
when he comes what is the position that
we must attain to all of these questions
are circulating on the Internet at the
moment and are clamoring for attention
so let us make it quite clear that
people understand where we are coming
from
we are seventh-day Adventists yes
now seventh-day Adventism doesn't always
have the best press if I can put it that
way but basically seventh-day Adventism
is very simple now I'm not a seventh-day
adventists because I subscribe to a
particular Creed that has been set up by
a group which is known as seventh-day
Adventist I'm a Bible believer yes this
is my this is my manual and without this
manual I would be totally lost
so my primary source of information is
the Word of God but there are thousands
of denominations that claim that their
primary source is the Word of God
correct so how do you read this primary
source and that is a very important
question so why am i a seventh-day
adventists let's make that quite clear
well let's break the name down
seventh-day adventists
there's a message in that it's not just
the name the message is you keep the
seventh-day because in Genesis it
already says and God blessed the seventh
day I guess I can actually go to Genesis
chapter 2 and see that this is not a
Jewish law at all it is a need any law
it comes from Eden thus the heavens and
the earth were finished this is now
Genesis chapter 2 and all the host of
them and on the seventh day God ended
his work which he had made and he rested
on the seventh day from all the work
which he had made and God blessed the
seventh day and sanctified it because
that in it he rested from all the work
which God created and made it's pretty
quite clear yeah it's an absolutely
clear statement now people were say how
do you know what the seventh day yes
because now they bring in lunar Sabbath
calendars and oldest well when God
created the cycle of the week there was
no moon to reckon from because that only
came on the fourth day right so he
couldn't have used the lunar sabbath to
determine the sabbath he was counting
the days and it it starts with and it
was evening and it was morning the first
day and
second day so it's accounting of the
days so how do we know that the seventh
day stole the seventh day and he he
blessed it and he set it aside for holy
use and it comes up over and over and
over as you go through the Old Testament
and it continues throughout the New
Testament it's not as though it just
suddenly disappears like some people
would like to say
now if the Sabbath was instituted in
Eden according to a cycle which God
established irrespective of a moon and
the Sun or whatever criterium just
basically on the counting of the days
then how do we know that we still of the
Sabbath today and the answer is simple
God instituted it in Eden if the Sabbath
should ever have been lost along the
line somewhere then when God took the
children of Israel before Sinai out of
Egypt he let the manna rain and the
manna fell and on a Friday there was
twice as much and on the Sabbath there
was none correct
so for forty years with a manna fell and
for 40 years he drove into their minds
and into their innermost being which day
was the Sabbath because there was none
on the Sabbath and on the preparation
day that is the day before the Sabbath
day was twice as much yes he spoke it in
great solemnity from Mount Sinai so if
ever it should have been lost between
creation and a later stage it was
certainly reinstated right there isn't
that correct correct okay so now what if
the Jews have gotten that mixed up and
mr. day somewhere would they then have
the same Sabbath store well the answer
is really quite simple
should they have lost it which they
didn't but should they have lost it then
very definitely it is reinstated when
you get to the crucifixion yes because
it says it was the preparation when
Jesus was crucified he was dead that
died at the ninth hour which is round
about three o'clock in the afternoon he
was in the grave they rushed to get him
into the grave and then they rested in
accordance with the commandment and very
early on the first day of the week the
new translations even say Sunday no he
rose from the dead so they rested
according to the commandment as his
custom was on the Sabbath as Paul's
custom was on the Sabbath I mean it's
there so what calendar was in effect in
the New Testament it was the Julian
calendar so the Julian calendar was in
effect so you know exactly what day that
was now the Julian calendar was changed
into the Gregorian calendar at the
initiative of Pope Gregory and that
calendar changed the days mean changed
the dates yes but never changed the
cycle of the week so it maintained the
exact same cycle so the Sabbath has
never been lost and all the great
astronomical studies that have been made
clearly show that the seventh day is
Saturday and you can take an ordinary
oxford dictionary and look up Saturday
yes and it'll tell you it's the seventh
day of the week and you can look up the
word Sunday and it will tell you it's
the
day of the week so seventh-day Adventist
Adventist is someone who believes that
Jesus Christ will come again and if you
want to take a very simple text to look
at some of these issues you can go to
John chapter 14 which which I love
because it is a mini Bible in one verse
explaining the whole doctrines where
Jesus says let not your hearts be trauma
we should all know this verse off by
heart by the way you believe in God
believe also in me and my father's house
are many mansions if it were not so I
would have told you yes then there's the
promise I go to prepare a place for you
and if I go and prepare a place for you
I will come again
that's an Adventist he believes that
Jesus is going to come again not on some
assumption the Bible is replete with the
promise of the coming of Christ in fact
it's the Blessed hope that was the verse
that made it all clear for me very clear
for you in becoming an Adventist okay so
you were not an Adventist all your life
neither was I and let me make it quite
plain it will take a tremendous amount
of conviction before anybody in his
right mind will change from what he was
in the world to become a seventh-day
Adventist life it's either a record of
total insanity
oh it must be based on something very
substantial right that's if you ask me
that's what does and that word is truth
truth okay so let's just finish this
I go to prepare a place for you and if I
go and prepare a place for you I will
come again and receive you unto myself
that where I am there ye may be also now
if you analyze this verse when will
God's people be with him when he comes
to give H you now what is the popular
theology say that everybody goes to
heaven as soon as they die so what's the
point of coming again to fits them if
they're there already right exactly no
point whatsoever and he's going to
prepare a place and he's going to come
again and and you know the seventh day
is one of the ten commandments yes and
if you read on here in in this beautiful
chapter John chapter 14 in verse 15 says
if you love me keep my Commandments yes
and I will pray the father and he will
give you another comforter that he may
be able to abide with you forever
and he's the spirit of truth and you
said truth right that's it so this is
all fascinating then verse 21 says he
that has my Commandments and keepeth
them he it is that loveth me me that's
not it's not rocket science
now and it's not it doesn't mention
there nine Commandments no it says all
of them and and and John is the author
of this of this gospel and he's citing
Jesus Christ later on in his in his
epistles he gets a little bit more
forceful and says he that says he loves
him and keeps not his Commandments is a
liar
and the truth is not in them so you know
but what is it to be an Adventist it's
someone who keeps the seventh-day yes
because he's learned to love God and
therefore he keeps his Commandments
not because he's forced to he is
convicted yes that's a I I think it was
James white that said and I had life the
phrase we don't keep the commandments to
be saved we keep the commandments
because we are saved
exactly so it is a it is something that
flows out of the relationship that you
have developed in any case so a
seventh-day Adventist is someone who
takes God at His Word it believes that
God created the world in six days that
was a major problem for me yes I mean I
was an evolutionist now I was an atheist
I mean this is ridiculous God created
the world in six days until you start
studying it and then you you find so
much evidence that your cage is totally
rattled right and if people want to
watch there's a whole series on creation
evolution that I did I wrote a book
called Genesis conflict and I mean the
evidence is just overwhelming I cannot
even believe that I used to be an
evolutionist a convicted evolutionist
yes so that is what it means to be a
seventh-day adventists
and an Adventist has a particular
message and has a particular
Constitution if you like and you find
that in Revelation chapter 12 and 13 and
let me just read what it says there
after giving a description of the
Christian Church and its persecutions
through the ages and an Adventist
believes the evangelical gospel love
of protestantism and so it talks here
about the the persecution in the Middle
Ages and all of these issues and then it
talks about a remnant with which the
dragon the devil is not very pleased
yeah and it says and the dragon was
wroth with the woman and a woman in the
Bible is a church and went to make war
with the remnant of her seed so the last
Church on earth what will it look like
and the criteria is which keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ
those are two criteria the two legs the
two legs and then they have this
particular message and Revelation
chapter 13 is a very heart of the
message and it describes the beasts of
Revelation 13 which are conglomerate
beasts of Daniel chapter 7 by the way
and another power another political
power that will enforce these entities
and we discussed that last time and we
we referred the people to the lecture
the two beasts become friends so here is
a particular message that is given and
we find it particularly in Revelation
chapter 14 there's a remnant that keeps
the commandments of God because again in
chapter 14 in verse 12 it refers to this
criteria where it says here is the
patience of the saints here are they
which keep the commandments of God and
have the faith of Jesus which is more
than the faith in Jesus right it entails
the faith in Jesus but it also believes
what Jesus believed yes and then it
gives the three angels messages and I
saw another angel flying in the midst of
heaven and then there are these three
angels the first one is the everlasting
gospel and that you must worship God who
is the creator and the sign of his
creation is the Sabbath great and the
second one is
the religious systems of the world that
reject these basic truths become part of
Babylon and the third one is do not
accept the mark of the beast that's what
all these questions were about yes
there's a lot of confusion about the
mark of the beast
now we spoke about that last time so I
don't think we should repeat it that
you've got all the links to the in-depth
studies about it but there was this
question about the mark being received
in the hand and in the forward so people
said but that definitely now refers to
the chip that will be implanted under
the skin because it says in the hand and
in the forehead
well let me put you your mind at rest
the Bible also says that God will give
his saints a place in his throne now
excuse me if you want to take that in
terms of the Linguistics of modern
English are you going to set within the
throne or you're going to be boxed up
within the throne so when the Bible
talks about in you will be in the throne
that means you will be totally part of
the decision-making it has to do with
decision making so it's interesting that
when you when you read about the seal of
God which is a Sabbath by the way yes
God says that he will write his laws in
our hearts right and he says that this
the seal of the Sabbath must be in the
hand and in the forehead and he says and
and not or not or whereas the mark of
the beast can be either in the hand or
the forehead now what does that mean
well if you receive it in the hand
it means you will act accordingly
not necessarily by conviction
but by compulsion because there's a law
and if you don't obey the law then well
you won't be able to buy or sell so
therefore you go along with it whether
you agree with it or not you receive it
in the hand those that receive it in the
forehead well in the forward behind the
forehead is your frontal lobe
with your decision-making capacity is
then you will have received it by
conviction now there are many preachers
that preach that the first day of the
week is now the new Sabbath and that is
their conviction without one single
Bible verse to corroborate their view so
this is the issue what are we going to
believe are we going to believe the Word
of God as it stands so are we going to
believe the theologians as they perceive
it if I can ask you on that point a lot
of them say that Sunday is the Lord's
Day yes now if you go look at this word
the Lord's Day there are only two places
where actually talks about this and the
one is in Isaiah where it says that the
Sabbath is the Lord's Day Jesus says
that he is Lord of the Sabbath and John
is in vision on the Lord's Day now with
what right do you say that that is
Sunday only by papal decree has it been
called Sunday there is no verse which
says that he was envisioned on a Sunday
so that is a pure conjecture on the side
of Roman Catholicism which has been
absorbed by the evangelicals the Bible
is very clear the Lord's Day is Saturday
the Sabbath day as I chapter 58 Jesus
was referring to the Sabbath day when he
said he was Lord of the Sabbath and John
was in vision on the Lord's Day
which is the Sabbath and without a
counter-argument to prove it otherwise
that's the way it is yes so those are
the issues and we can jump to another
issue that they the people also have is
the secret rapture yes now is there a
secret secret rapture well the Bible
says the coming of the Son of Man will
be like lightning that is visible from
the east to the west
the Bible says that if you here is here
and if you here is their needs in the
inner room noise in the desert do not go
because coming will be universally
visible now there's nothing secret about
the universally visible coming of Christ
what will happen at the coming of Christ
God will separate the wicked from the
just so the use of verse like for
example two will be grinding at a
grindstone one will be taken and the
other one not now it's not going to the
depth of that verse but where does it
say that the one is taken secretly
doesn't say that at all
everywhere in the Bible it says God will
give his angels charge and they will
come and they will separate the wicked
from the just and it says that those
that are living the righteous living
will be changed in an instant in the
twinkling of an eye and the resurrected
in Christ together with them will be
taken and meet the Lord in the end now
excuse me where does the secret rapture
come from and where is this resurrection
of the just that has to take place
simultaneously with the translation of
the living those aspects are not in that
theology at all so where is this
theology come from
it's a Jesuit theology it's not a
biblical theology and none of the
reformers ever believed it so it is a
modern evangelical view
that has been taken over from a
Jesuitical teaching which was introduced
to take the heat of the papacy as
Antichrist because that is what the
Reformers said the Reformers said that
the papacy was Antichrist and so the
Jesuits came up with two
counter-reformation theologists
theologies futurism and preterism
critter ISM for the Antichrist
activities into the past and they
claimed that a Greek king Antiochus it
before Anna's for fulfilled the criteria
of the little horn power of Daniel and
that that was the Antichrist now it's
not biblical because the Bible says in
Daniel that the Antichrist comes out of
the fourth beast which is Rome and not
out of the third beast which is Greece
so it cannot be a Greek king now it's
interesting that the the conservative
theological seminaries and universities
first adopted this pre tourism yes and
said that it was Antiochus Epiphanes I
had had an evangelical I want to mention
the denomination comes to my home and he
gave me that theory and I went through
Daniel chapter 7 with him and I said now
please explain to me this power comes
out of the fourth beast and yours now
comes out of the third beast so how do
you explain that he got so upset that he
had a young man with him he he closed
his ears and he marched him out of the
house so that he shouldn't become
confused by what the Bible says on that
issue now the other one is is futurism
when they say the Antichrist will come
in the future what they do there is they
take the last week of the seventy weeks
of Daniel
yes and transported into the future
there's also where the Shrieker rapture
links on to correct
now this theology again is a Jesuit
theology and it was embellished by
Cardinal Bellamy no as a Jesuit and this
theology is believed by the evangelicals
today it was never believed by the
Reformers they were absolutely clear and
you don't have to be an Adventist to
understand it you can go to the the
writings of the Reformers or you don't
even have to go to their writings which
are replete in that sort of thing you
can go to the Church of England
theologians for example grattan-guinness
this wrote a book Romanism and the
Reformation in which he takes the the
Protestant position and clearly
delineates it from the Book of Daniel
there is not a shadow of doubt as to
what they believed why don't they
believe it anymore has the Bible changed
definitely not the sentiment has changed
and you know do you know what brought it
in is when Protestantism changed its
starts that's when the problem came in
through a common ISM it was necessary to
lay aside doctrine in order to
accommodate the diversity that is out
there because if two walk together and
they have two different theologies well
it's going to create controversy yes so
let's put the doctor on the side in fact
the Pope said we have to put doctrine
aside yes so what becomes the norm then
the spirit yes
but the spirit that is not in harmony
with the word is not the Spirit of God
so the Reformers had this saying Sola
scriptura the Bible and the Bible alone
that's your criterion and if the spirit
speaks contrary to the word
then it's not the Spirit of God that's
why as ayah 8 verse 20 says to the law
which is the Torah the Bible and the
testimony is what the prophets wrote if
they speak not according to this word
they have no light in them and that is
where this confusion comes in we have to
get away from these evangelical
doctrines of a secret rapture because
there's no such thing in the Bible it
contradicts the very plainest verses and
we have to get back to the biblical
teaching of what it says in this word
but then this confusion would end
another issue that they bring up
constantly is the 5g and how this might
be the cause of coronavirus and all
sorts of other causes is there something
you would like to say on this I don't
know how many videos I've received in
how many documents regarding the 5g and
that this is the big issue at the moment
and is causing all the problems
be that as it may
is this what we are to concentrate on at
the moment for example let's just think
logically 5g they say that the radiation
is problematic well all radiation in a
sense is problematic now the human being
is exposed to so much radiation that
it's a astounding that we cope so well
and cell phones or Handy's as they call
them in some places they they work on a
microwave frequency and then this is
compared to the normal microwave that
cooks things and yes the vibrations are
very dangerous and we must take into
account the high concentrations
etc etc but whenever something new comes
out there's this this major hype about
what it can do to your body and yes we
have to be careful and we have to be
sensible and we have to protect
ourselves from all of these things now
5g they're saying has a frequency which
will interfere with oxygen absorption
and therefore these people have been
falling over
as a consequence of 5g now if that were
the case if there was a 5g transmitter
and it interfered with oxygen uptake
then why wouldn't many more people just
fall over why one here and one there and
you see all of these videos and it
creates fear and it creates suspicion
and the question I have are there is not
all side issues that are so gerd to
occupy our mind that we miss the point
do you basically didn't want to say that
we don't have to worry about like the 5g
and the chip that has to can be
implanted I've never said that we don't
have to worry about these things I said
these are not the issues that are the
heart of the biblical criteria that we
are talking about is it important to
make sure that I eat correctly so that I
protect my body yes so it's an important
issue correct but it is an issue that
enlightens my mind and makes me capable
of absorbing greater realities a health
and health reform is not my religion
it's a consequence of my religion my
body is not my own it belongs to God so
is it important that I protect myself
absolutely if I know something is
dangerous then I will protect myself if
I work in a radiology lab
and I work with x-rays am I going to
wear protective clothing obviously
because I know what the issue is can I
protect myself against every Wraith at
is out there in the world how many
arrays have we got right here around us
now at the moment yes unbelievable right
every little piece of information in the
entire world is floating around our ears
right now did you know that yes do you
know that do you know that passing
between us now in this sacred forum
where we're talking about the issues of
God
we have pornography streaming past us
right now did you know that all I need
is the right instrument to catch it and
I can watch it does that mean I want to
watch it no and if it pops up should I
watch it no so that is not the issue the
issue is what is happening now where are
we in the stream of time what must
happen in here in terms of my
relationship with God
that's what is what I'm saying if you
know that something is dangerous then
take every measure that you can to
protect yourself from whatever that
issue is and if you've done what you can
then you must leave the consequences to
God if I had to be concerned about what
I eat to the point of not trusting
anything in a store because I don't know
how they're prepared I could drive
myself insane this so you take the best
precautions that you can you wash your
food you try and buy the best food that
you can possibly buy for your body and
then you get to the point where you say
I've done what I can
yes and now I leave the consequences to
God I can take every device a cell phone
and I can throw it away because it is
dangerous but you're sitting right next
to me with a with a cell phone in your
pocket probably and so it's the next one
and the next one and all this
information is up there I have an
interesting theory I'm a way of the
topic now but who created all the
various forms of radiation did man
create them or did God create originally
yes all the things that we are now
harnessing with instruments we have an
instrument to harness everything if we
want to know about x-rays x-rays exist
yes but I need an instrument to monomyth
monitor it and to uses microwaves exist
right ultraviolet radiation exists I
cannot see ultraviolet but Abby can Abby
has an instrument to pick it up and to
actually see what's going on in a sphere
that I'm incapable of I'm wondering if
God has something exciting waiting for
us that one day we will be able to tune
into all of those frequencies and gain
information that he is put into the
world maybe one day I can look at a leaf
and actually look right into it to see
the very mechanisms of its workings I
don't know what the future is going to
be but it's going to be amazing that's
for sure
so we harness all of these things and
I'm not saying that certain things are
not dangerous or are dangerous what I'm
saying is when you get to the point
where there's nothing you can do about
it then focus on the greater realities
which are written in the Word of God I
agree all the side issues must become
small exactly you are talking about
other side issues the fees yes the anti
Trinitarian movement
so the deity of Christ the whatever what
were the others are kind of know like
we've mentioned the lunar Sabbath some
of these things let's not go there we've
spoken about it already in a sense but
to me a non-negotiable would be the
deity of Christ if Christ is not God
then he could not have laid down his
life and taken it up again he says
nobody takes it from me I lay it down
and I take it up again 1 John chapter 1
says at the beginning was the word and
the Word was with God and the Word was
God
everything was created by him and for
him without him was not anything created
Jesus so often referred to himself in
theistic language that the Jews picked
up stones to stone him because he was
making himself God he received worship
the deity of Christ to me is a
non-negotiable issue so when you talk
about the Trinity for example where they
say there's only there's one they start
with the Holy Spirit and say okay the
Holy Spirit is not part of the Godhead
it is the Spirit of Christ and the
spirit of the father so let's get rid of
that then we must all work to 1 and you
still have to write eventually they get
to the point where Christ is a lesser
deity he has a deity that has been given
him or lent him straighted being yeah
basically you get to the point where he
has to be a created being now that's
where I will draw the line the deity of
Christ is a non-negotiable for me and
therefore all of these arguments
which go round and round and round and
take the attention of God's people take
us away from the message for the time
and the message for the time is clearly
given in in the book of Revelation what
is present truth we have to restore the
everlasting gospel the gospel has never
changed now why is that important
because people out there teach a gospel
of dispensation which means that for
every generation period there is a
different way of salvation so you had
the period where you were saved by the
keeping the law and then you did away
with the law now you have to be saved by
grace yes without the law then in future
you'll have the dispensation of the
kingdom which again has different
criteria because the Christians won't be
there they will be raptured etc etc that
is so far removed from biblical teaching
then it boggles the mind how anyone
could accept this Jesuitical teaching
and let's face it the Jesuits have been
the enemies of the Word of God from the
beginning they called the Bible this
poisonous ASP you read their Creed yes
enough to give you jaws absolutely so it
is so far removed from this Bible as the
East is from the West as them as the
heavens are removed from the deepest
ocean where in the Bible do you have a
dispensation Adam and Eve were saved by
the blood of the Lamb there was a land
that was slaughtered and the coats that
they wore were the coat of the Lamb
in other words the righteousness of
Christ covered them Cain's offer was
rejected because he brought the works of
his hands Roman Catholicism insists that
you are safe but through works
and call it in the Nasmith to say that
you are saved and justified by the grace
of Christ alone canes offer was not
accepted Abel who brought the lamb
according to the criteria was accepted
because he realized salvation was
outside of him how was the juice saved
by keeping the law no he had to bring a
lamb juice he had to place his hands
upon the lamb he had to confess his sins
over the lamb he had to take the knife
and cut the throat of the lamb to
demonstrate the fact that he a sinner
was responsible for the death of the
anti-typical Lamb of God that John John
the Baptist referred to salvation has
always been through the blood of the
Lamb I think actually the Jews had it
not so easy as us know because their to
do it physically to see what the Savior
has done for us exactly another not the
other point is was obedience a
prerequisite for remaining in Eden
absolutely so when they disobeyed they
lost access to Eden right so now should
obedience not be a criterion at the end
did God realize he made a mistake and
doesn't require obedience then why does
he say not one jot or one tittle will by
any means disappear out of the law and
that nothing in the law will be changed
why does he insist upon the fact that
only those that keep the commandments of
God will have access to the Tree of Life
revelation 22 verse 14 absolutely and
what is the revelation 22 verse 15 it
tells you if you don't keep them a
Commandments in your part of the rest of
the exactly people that stayed outside
of it so it has never changed so this
gospel of dispensations which is the
evangelical norm in many many circles is
a chance of a doctrine which is not
perfect which
never believed by the Reformers and
should never be believed by anyone who
trusts in this word of God let me say it
categorically you have all of these
arguments that you now have to let's say
keep the feasts I'm not arguing the fact
whether we should or should not I'm just
saying you have all of these issues
coming in the anti Trinitarian doctrine
the feasts of the lunar Sabbath of this
that the perfectionism and all of this
is geared to keep the Saints busy but
what is their job why did Jesus come to
this world why did Jesus leave the
ninety-nine saved angels behind to come
and seek and save the lost on this
planet because he loved us and love like
a pair is unselfish love it doesn't
revolve around self all of those issues
revolve around self am i perfect am I
good enough I'm not saying that you
mustn't strive to do what is right I'm
not saying that at all I'm saying these
issues of keeping God's people busy
instead of preaching the gospel to the
Lost we are focusing on self and it
should stop this we should have one
mission I know what I believe and I must
work up my salvation my own salvation
with fear and trembling before God and I
have a personal relationship with him
and that is what everybody should have
and you need time to study the Word of
God and you need to have time to be with
God but you have a commission yes and
the Commission is go ye into all the
world and preach the gospel the ever
lasting gospel
at the everlasting gospel that has never
changed that is our commission and if we
miss that point because we're so
concerned with our own self then we will
miss out on a major blessing because
only as you give to others can you
receive yourself it is a double-edged
sword and only as you forgive you are
forgiven and one more point if you do
not believe exactly like any of these
groups believe you are apostate so when
I read what some of these people say and
some of the web pages out there I must
be the most apostate person on the
planet because everybody has a gripe
either this group or that group or
whatever
within and without the church yes let me
say it again categorically I'm a
seventh-day adventists as far as the
church is concerned I am what they say
in good and regular standing I am an
ordained minister of the church and I
have received many labels in the church
in the church and without the church
some claim I'm a conspiracist why
because I believe what the Bible says in
Revelation and what it says in the Book
of Daniel and it is amazing to me that
that which we have preached for over
thirty years in my case is fulfilling
before our very eyes
so was it a conspiracy or was it a
prophecy and some people yeah he was
just I think make it clear that you
don't say you're a prophet because some
people might now put that label on you
that would be the most Orenda thing that
could ever happen
I'm just someone who loves the Word of
God I am fascinated with prophecy in
fact prophecy pulled the rug out from
under my feet if you don't mind if I can
come here with a side note because I
would before we close off I would like
it to discuss this as well because
Adventism stands on two legs and you
mentioned the one already we've
discussed the commandments would you
mind bringing and the other leg now with
all this prophecy that you're gonna be
talking about yes era they that keep the
commandments and have the testimony of
Jesus and the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of prophecy prophecy is a very
central part of Adventism as well
now prophecy was a tremendous part of
Protestantism in fact the very first
book that Martin Luther translated from
the Old Testament was the Book of Daniel
yes I mean if you start translating the
old test Testament why wouldn't you
start with the book of Genesis why would
you start with the book of Daniel and he
said God's people need the Book of
Daniel so we can understand where we are
in the stream of time and because all of
these prophecies in the Book of Daniel
culminate with the coming of Christ and
when I started studying the Bible and I
found Daniel Daniel chapter 2 Daniel
chapter 7 Daniel chapter 8 and 9 and and
you see these magnificent prophecies and
you don't have to take an Adventist word
go as I said read grattan-guinness
Romanism and the Reformation and you can
see exactly what the Reformers believed
and how logical their arguments were
they are indisputable in their logic
when I studied that I realized that this
may not be lost
and it changed me from an atheist to a
believer because how could God with such
accuracy hundreds of years before the
events described these issues with the
exact year of the coming of Messiah
predicted in the Bible and then all the
issues pertaining to the end and what
would happen and if being fulfilled one
after the other before our very eyes we
should actually have a talk as to
exactly where we are in the stream of
time because people believe could still
be hundreds of years before Christ comes
now it is at the door even at the door
and we need to talk about I think we can
work that into a special edition special
episode that we can we need to talk
about that and we need to be careful
that we don't mix the prophetic
interpretation of the Bible with the
interpretation that has been given by
futurist thinking the
counter-reformation which comes from the
courts of the jesuits so we have to
clearly distinguish them so yes I'm a
Seventh day Adventist and I don't
believe that I am apostate even if some
of these people think that I think
differently from them therefore I must
be off the wall somewhere and it's
important that if people say that I have
become this or that or the other don't
believe it I'm just a old fashioned
Adventist who believes as the Pioneers
believed I believe the Bible I believe
the spirit of prophecy
I believe in obedience to God's
requirements not as a means to salvation
but as a consequence of salvation and I
believe that the final message
the world is three angels message and
that all of these side issues you can
study them if you like in your private
time but when it comes to your public
time concentrate on the Word of God
perhaps we can discuss the spirit of
prophecy in a broader terms in a next
episode absolutely we can do that thank
you very much we'll see you next time
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click yes when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time